we haven't heard from him in seven days  but now Victor Yanukovych is back on the  scene and he's scathing of the new  authorities in Kiev yeah Wimbledon will  perk image okay you know I was forced to  leave Ukraine because my life and the  lives of those dear to me were under  threat God was notable cleaner less as  you are aware power in Ukraine has been  seized by nationalists pro-fascist  youngsters representing an absolute  minority in Ukraine mentioned stores  readily agreed Yanukovych angrily  pointed his finger at Western countries  he said provoked the crisis Billy is  really a purpose silly it's the unrest  and the victims the loss of life these  are all consequences of this political  crisis this is a result of irresponsible  policies of the West who indulged the  Maidan protesters my gun Yanukovych also  said he hadn't met the Russian president  since fleeing but that he was surprised  by vadoma Putin's silence on the issue